our Jon Gosselin exclusive interview
that he said will be one of his last he
gave us a rare update on the sex
couplets who are now 16 and he also
filled us in on why the drama with his
ex Kate is far from over
it has now been ten years since you
divorced Kate don't play victim
what are those ten years in my cream hmm
I have learned a lot I've had a lot of
lessons but I bounced back I've made
great relationships I've had bad
relationships
I've grown I'm happy where I am now I
know a lot about court after custody
battles therapy sessions and so many
tabloid headlines hard to believe John
and Kate's adorable sextuplets just
turned 16 as for physical custody right
now well it's complicated because
they're over 14 in Pennsylvania
custody is up to them so like my custody
I have custody of Hannah and Collin and
she has custody of four and many Cara
adults
Mike is Hannah and Collin I live with me
I want to be left alone and they just
want to have a normal teenage life
speaking of normal 43 year old John's
more settled than ever his DJ life has
been put on hold he works as an IT
director of a health care facility and
he's had the same steady girlfriend for
six years there's really just one
glaring issue his kids are divided into
two camps I wish that all my kids would
just be together I feel like it's East
and West Germany kind of you know
because Nick and I don't live that far
away from each other and I feel like
there's an invisible wall who's stopping
them from coming together no I'm not
stopping them from coming together I
can't speak for the other side so I'm
hoping that when my kids and they will
get their license and when I say my kids
I'm referring to Hannah and Collin that
they'll just drive to school and pick up
their siblings and legally no one can
stop them from doing so
do they miss your siblings oh yeah
absolutely
absolutely have you heard from Kate
saying that the other four missed their
siblings also I don't hear from Kate
it's just totally like that person
doesn't exist anymore how do the older
girls feel about this
I don't know because they haven't talked
to me in six years or seven years I'm
Nydia you took Kate decor for shooting
on the show I took Kate to court for
illegally filming my kids without work
permits as for Kate's life today I'm
dating again finally she's been laying
low since her last reality show Kate
Plus date came to an end on TLC last
year what two or three things do you
enjoy doing but you can still see the 45
year old on social media she's been
making tic toc videos with the kids I
have no regrets in my life
do you regret during reality TV I don't
regret it I mean financially my kids are
in there education will be definitely
taken care of I think it was weird I
guess being the first family on reality
TV or the pioneers are you gonna be the
reality show star with the happy ending
I already think it is happy what message
would you have for your four other kids
who aren't with you now what would you
say to them Leah Aaden Joel and Alexis I
love you I don't know what the lol is I
love you both of you call or call Hannah
thank you couldn't walk to my house it's
all good
[Music]